I have a system of two equations with
two unknowns here we've seen how to
solve this and there's multiple
techniques we've used substitution
elimination and we could do that right
over here in fact you could just add the
two the left sides of the equations and
the right sides of the equations the
esses would cancel out actually let's
just do it to show how that's relatively
straightforward for at least of this
example right over here you add the
left-hand sides these cancel out you're
left with negative T negative T is equal
to is equal to 7 plus negative 6 is
equal to 1 or you get the T is equal to
negative 1 T is equal to negative 1 and
if T is equal to negative 1 this top
this top equation you could use either
one would simplify to 2 times s negative
5 times negative 1 is plus 5 plus 5 is
equal to 7 is equal to let me use those
same colors that we have over there is
equal to 7 or and we could do this part
in our head 2's must be equal to 2 and
that s is equal to 1/2 times 1 plus 5 is
7 and so we have s is equal to 1 so that
was pretty straightforward
what we're going to do in this video is
represent the same system but we're
going to represent it essentially as a
matrix equation and we're going to solve
it using inverse matrices and I'll give
you a little bit of a warning it's going
to be more involved it's going to take
us more time to this and you're probably
going to say well why are we even going
through the trouble of it and the value
of what we're going to do in this video
is that it's very useful in computation
where you might solve almost the same
system over and over and over again
maybe the left-hand sides are the same
the right hands keep changing and this
might be something that you you might
see while writing a computer game or
awhile while working on you know some
type of a computer problem and so and
this is a general theme a lot of the
value of matrices are they are ways to
represent problems mathematical problems
ways to represent data and they there
and then we can use matrix operations
matrix equations to essentially
manipulate them in a
waise if we're for the most part writing
computer programs or things like
computer programs so bear with me you
will enjoy it eventually what we're
about to do and one day you will see
that it is actually quite useful so the
first thing we need to see or need to
appreciate is that this can be
represented by a matrix equation now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take the coefficients here so I'm going
to take the coefficients here so 2
negative 5 to negative 5 negative 2
negative 2 and 4 and positive 4 so all
I've done is I've taken the coefficients
here and I'm going to claim that that
times the column vector column vector St
s and T being equal to be equal to the
column vector being equal to the column
vector 7 negative 6 7 negative 6 is the
exact same thing as what we have right
over here these are representing the
same constraints on the variable s and T
so why don't I don't quite get that and
if you're saying you don't quite get
that multiply this out multiply this out
and think about which entries they need
to be equal to when you multiply it out
and you would see well this entry this
first row first column that's going to
be this row we're going to be dealing
with this row and that column so if you
think about it it's going to be this
this tells us that 2 2 times s 2 times s
plus negative 5 times T so I could say
minus 5 times T must be equal to the
first entry up here first row first
column is equal to 7 all I did is I
multiplied I dealt with the first row
first column it said well when I when I
take essentially the dot product of
those and we if you don't know what a
dot product is don't worry we'll explain
it other places it's essentially what I
just did here the first and the first
entry here times the first entry the
second entry here times the second entry
and we add them together that that must
be equal to 7 but when you do that you
essentially construct this first
equation and when you do it with a
second
and this column you construct the second
equation you get negative two times s
negative two times s plus four times T
plus four times t four times T is equal
to negative six is equal to negative six
is equal to negative six so hopefully
you appreciate that this contains the
same information as that and there's
other ways that I could have done it for
example you could have instead of
writing it this way obviously this
system is obviously the same thing is
obviously the same thing as and actually
let me just copy and paste it is the
same thing as so copy and paste is the
same thing as this system where I'm
really just swapping so once again copy
and paste I'm just obviously I've
written the second one first and I've
written the first one second so these
this is obviously the same system and so
if I wanted to construct a matrix
equation with this system I would just
swap all of the rows the first row here
would be negative 2 4 and well I would
swap the rows for the coefficients but I
would still keep the s and T's in the
same order and you could do that try to
try to represent this right over here as
a matrix equation you would have the
matrix here would be negative 2 4 2
negative 5 and this would be negative 6
7 but now that we've set this up how do
we actually solve something like this
why do we even do this and to think
about this let's actually think about it
in terms of literally a matrix equation
so let's say that a the matrix a is this
thing right over here
this thing over here is the matrix a
let's say that this right over here this
is the column vector X and since so I'll
write it as a vector X right over here
so you have the column vector X and then
this right over here you could say that
this is equal it what's called us the
column vector B so this is equal to the
column vector B so we're essentially
saying that a the matrix a time's the
column vector X is equal to is equal to
the column vector B let me write that
and right over here just to emphasize it
the matrix a time's the column vector X
is going to be equal to is equal to the
column vector B and so this is what
they're talking about when they say a
matrix equation and actually even before
we even think about computation and
computer graphics and all that you will
see a lot of things like this in physics
where they're speaking in general terms
where there might not even be specifying
the dimensions of the matrix or the
dimensions of this vector but they're
talking about some general property and
say physics and so you will see vector
equal matrix vector equations like this
a lot as you get into higher and higher
Sciences but once again let's just just
go back to our core issue of how do we
actually solve this well one way you
could think about it we've already seen
that if a matrix is invertible that
means that there's a matrix a inverse
that exists such that a inverse times a
is equal to the identity is equal to the
identity matrix so what if we multiplied
the left-hand sides of both sides of
this equation by a inverse remember
order matters when you are multiplying
matrices so we multiply the left-hand
sides of both sides of the equation by a
inverse which would get us a inverse
times a times X is equal to is equal to
a inverse remember I'm multiplying the
left-hand sides of both equations a
inverse times the column vector B now
why is this interesting well we just
said that the inverse times a assuming
that a is invertible that this right
over here is going to be equal to the
identity matrix so that's going to be
the identity matrix times column vector
column vector X and that's going to be
equal to that's going to be equal to
this stuff that's going to be equal to
that so let me just copy and paste that
that's going to be equal to that now why
is that interesting well the identity
matrix times some
some other matrix this column vector
essentially is a two by one matrix
that's just going to be this column
vector again so it's just going to
simplify to that our column vector is
equal to our column vector is equal to
the inverse matrix times our column
vector or cut or our column vector X is
equal to the inverse matrix times the
column vector B and so once again
emphasizing why is this useful well yes
you do have to go through the trouble of
calculating a inverse but once you've
done that you could keep swapping in
different different bees you know this
one is seven negative six but you can
have other bees here and if you're
running a computer program you want to
do this over and over again you just
have to do multiple matrix
multiplications so I'll leave that
thought here I've realized that I'm
approaching ten minutes which I never
like to cross in these videos in the
next video we'll actually compute what a
inverse is and calculate what the
solution vector X is